SIMILAR FLOODING EVENT IN 2020
MAY EXPERIENCE FLOODING AGAIN
THIS TIME AROUND.
FOR MORE ON THIS, JOINING ME NOW
IS THE MAYOR OF JACKSON,
MISSISSIPPI, MAYOR CHOKWE
LUMUMBA.
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US ON I'M
SURE IS A VERY BUSY WEEKEND.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR
MESSAGE TO RESIDENTS NOW.
YOU HAD A NEWS CONFERENCE, A LOT
OF URGENCY IN YOUR VOICE, THE
MESSAGE WAS FOR RESIDENTS TO GET
OUT NOW, THE RESIDENTS IN THE
LOW LYING AREAS.
IS THERE STILL TIME TO GET OUT?
>> YES, THERE IS.
BUT THAT SHOULD BE EXECUTED AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEEN THESE EVENTS AS RECENTLY AS
2020, WE HAVE A REFERENCE POINT
AND WE KNOW THE DAMAGE THAT CAN
OCCUR.
WE'RE ASKING THE RESIDENTS TO
HEED THE WARNINGS BEING PROVIDED
TO THEM.
WE HAVE A COALITION THAT HAS
RESPONDED EARLY AND OFTEN, GOING
FROM BOTH CITY DEPARTMENTS TO
THE COUNTY, ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE STATE.
AND SO I'M VERY PLEASED WITH
COALITION AND THEIR RESPONSE.
NOW WE NEED OUR RESIDENTS TO
TAKE HEED TO THESE WARNINGS AND
MOVE OUT QUICKLY.
>> ARE YOU SEEING PEOPLE
LISTENING TO THAT WARNING?
>> BY AND LARGE, BY AND LARGE.
BUT WE, YOU KNOW, IF WE RISK THE
LIFE OF ONE INDIVIDUAL, THAT IS
ONE INDIVIDUAL TOO MANY.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
WE KNOW THAT BOTH PEOPLE AND
INDIVIDUALS, PETS, AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOME PROPERTY CAN BE
SAVED, THAT IT IS ALL SPARED DUE
TO EARLY PREPARATION.
>> SO WE WERE SAYING THAT THE
PEARL RIVER, WHICH, YOU KNOW,
RUNS THROUGH JACKSON AND SOUTH
TO LOUISIANA IS EXPECTED TO
CREST TOMORROW MORNING AT 36
FEET.
CAN YOU GIVE US SOME CONTEXT
HERE?
IT IS SUPPOSED TO CREST AT 36
FEET.
WHAT ARE THE NORMAL LEVELS?
AND WHAT ARE YOU MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT?
>> WELL, WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
100 TO 150 HOMES THAT ARE IN
NORTHEAST JACKSON AND SOME HOMES
THAT ARE SOUTH OF US, SOUTH
JACKSON, THAT, YOU KNOW, DURING
THESE EVENTS TEND TO BE THE ONES
AFFECTED.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED BECAUSE OUR
RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN INUNDATED
WITH PERSISTENT RAIN OVER THE
LAST FEW DAYS.
SO WE ALREADY HAVE BEEN
CONTENDING WITH FLASH FLOODING,
AND SO IT IS QUITE A TOLL ON OUR
RESIDENTS.
SO, WE'RE JUST TRYING TO MAKE
CERTAIN WE'RE PRESENT FOR THEM.
36 FEET IS QUITE OBVIOUSLY A
VERY SCARY AREA FOR THEM TO --
FOR THE RIVER TO REACH.
I THINK AROUND 31 FEET IS WHAT
WE NORMALLY SEE.
SO I DON'T WANT TO, YOU KNOW,
STATE THAT AS AN EXACT
MEASUREMENT, BUT I DO KNOW 36
FEET IS FAR TOO HIGH.
>> YEAH.
CONCERNING ENOUGH TO GET PEOPLE
TO GET OUT AS SOON AS THEY CAN.
TELL US ABOUT THE PREPARATIONS
THAT ARE UNDER WAY AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE SEARCH
AND RESCUE TEAMS ON STAND BY AS
WELL.
BUT, OF COURSE, YOU KNOW, THE
HOPE IS YOU DON'T HAVE TO USE
THE SEARCH AND RESCUE TEAMS.
TELL US MORE ABOUT THE
PREPARATIONS.
>> WELL, WE HAD THE COORDINATION
OF BOTH THE JACKSON POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND FIRE DEPARTMENT
ALONG WITH THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
WE HAVE NEMA THAT HAS BEEN ON
THE GROUND AND ALSO WILDLIFE AND
FISHERIES HAS ALL JOINED INTO
THIS EFFORT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
WE HAVE PREPARATIONS FOR SEARCH
AND RESCUE.
OUR PUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN CLEARING AREAS OF DEBRIS
THAT THEY CAN.
THEY HAVE BEEN PREPARING
SANDBAGS AND ISSUING THEM TO
RESIDENTS.
OUR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION,
JTRAN, HAS BEEN OFFERING
ASSISTANCE TO RESIDENTS WHO
DON'T HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
VEHICLES IN ORDER TO EVACUATE AS
EARLY AS THEY CAN.
OF COURSE, THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS HAS BEEN ON THE SCENE.
THEY'RE OPERATING A SHELTER AND
POLICE TRAINING ACADEMY TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE RESIDENTS THAT
HAVE NO OTHER RECOURSE CAN SEEK
SHELTER THERE.
WE HAVE ACTUALLY INSTRUCTED OUR
RESIDENTS TO, YOU KNOW, PREPARE
KITS FOR AS LONG AS UP TO TWO
WEEKS BECAUSE WE KNOW EVEN WHILE
THE EVENT MAY BE PROJECTED TO
HIT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN MONDAY AND
TUESDAY, THAT THAT WATER CAN BE
WITH US FOR SOME TIME AND SO
WE'RE ASKING T